ned stark is a very honorable man
you know when there are certain things
that bother him and one of them
is the killing of children
this produced uh a rift
between robert and him during back
during the rebellion when
king's landing fell and the lannister
men
killed prince rhaegar's two young
children
and laid wrapped a little bodies and
cloaks and presented them to robert
ned was sickened by this and quarreled
with robert over it
when he finds out about the incest
between cersei and
jaime and deduces that
as john aaron did before him that the
queen's three children
none of them are fathered by robert ned
knows
that if he tells robert this robert's
rage will be unbounded i mean cersei
will
certainly die jaime will probably die
but also the children will die robert
will
will put these three children to death
these these uh illegitimate kids and
it'll be a repetition of
the nightmare that he remembers from
from the fall of king's landing
and his honor and his decency brought
him
to meet with cersei and tell her what
he's learned
and to warn her
to leave king's landing to take the
children and flee because
robert's wrath is is going to follow
them to the ends of the earth
but it's the only way he sees that she
can save those
so three kids of of hers
so it's it's an honorable thing to do
but of course
in terms of sheer power politics and
guile it's a foolish thing to do
the hand is the prime minister he's the
the chief counselor of the king he
speaks for the king with the king's
voice when the king is not
available um he's the king's chief
counselor
when when the council assembles and all
that robert has depended on
john aaron his kind of surrogate father
um for all these years but now john
aaron is dead and he has to find a new
hand
and ned stark is the man that he trusts
most
his boyhood friend the companion who
fought beside him in the war
um but who is far removed from the
intrigues of king's landing i mean
robert could much more easily have
chosen a present council member
he could have turned to his brother
stannis he could have turned
to one of the lannisters lord tywin
for example who was the hand of the mad
king for many years and was very
qualified
a very strong and competent hand he
could have turned to him he could have
turned to jaime lannister
which is what cersei wants his queen
wants he doesn't want any of those
people
he doesn't trust any of those people he
wants
ned who he trusted who he grew up with
who helped him win the throne but of
course by selecting
ned he's making
enemies elsewhere among the people he's
not selecting
so that starts a lot of things rolling
lady is sentenced to die
but it's ned who takes it on himself to
to do it
because of the the ethos of the starks
which says the man who passes the satan
should swing the sword
you know he's not going to give his
daughters
wolf to to any of the lannisters to kill
he's going to do it himself as as
compassionately as it is it's a
difficult task but
if it has to be done uh he'll do it
so it says something about him and of
course that scene also says something
about
robert and that's ominous i think is
that robert doesn't stand up to cersei
in that scene when she demands
you know lady was completely innocent of
the whole of the whole incident
but she's being a little vindictive
there and robert is caving in before him
and that gives you i think an indication
of the character robert too
robert does not like that kind of
conflict
robert likes the kind of conflict that
he can win by hitting his opponent with
a warhammer but he doesn't like
the kind of verbal argument
wrangling and back and forth and
that sort of thing just drives him crazy
he just wants it over with okay you want
that i don't care about that
do it let's stop this you know
how stark is thousands of years old
they have ruled the north
going back into the mists of time
but for the last 300 years they have
only been lords
they have been subservient to the iron
throne
when aegon the conqueror came
and he conquered most of the southern
kingdoms
tauren stark had come south
with a large army of north men to
confront him but after the field for
fire he knew it was doomed and
so he knelt and he was the last king of
the north
and the first who was simply lord of
winterfell
and a vassal of the iron throne ruling
as
a as a secondary ruler
subject to the the laws of the
targaryens
but that was only 300 years ago before
that you have thousands of years of
history in which the starks were kings
at the time of the scene
we're talking about the targaryens have
been deposed
that was the house that niltu
the targaryens the baratheons have
effectively been deposed because
robert is dead and the new king
joffrey is not in fact actually his heir
but his pure lannister
and the lords of the north and the lords
of the riverlands who are present at the
same time
who are allied with robb stark by
virtue of his mother and that whole
house tully bloodline um don't see why
they
should be subject to this lannister king
why make a peace and just go back to
being the lord
why not go back to being the the
separate kingdom again so they hail rob
as the king in the north and he becomes
the first
the first stark to actually wear a crown
for
300 years